if you ever feel really stressed one day
if you're like man I have a lot of
anxiety like there's a lot of stuff
going on just try this put earplugs in
put headphones on top you will literally
feel the world get quieter all of a
sudden you're like it gets you into a
little bit more of a meditative State
because the only thing you can hear is
your breath for me when I work imagine
this environment I have this massive
screen so the only thing I look at is my
work I have no windows I have a timer
that's keeping me on task and I have two
things stopping any noise from getting
in my work per unit of time that I'm
allocating to it goes up by a lot